alright guys I got a special treat for
you today we've got Dan here who sits in
a very unique aspect of the crypto
ecosystem thank you so much for coming
sir
Thank You pomp for having me excited to
be here absolutely let's do a little bit
on your background and how you
eventually discovered crypto and that we
can get into what you're doing with the
vision Hill sure so I started my career
in valuation and transaction advisory I
was up in Phelps 50 years focused on
structured product evaluation so these
are your credit derivatives asset-backed
securities mortgage servicing rights and
other forms of capital structure
solutions so very deeply analytical and
navigated over to the buyer side where
join Citigroup a few years ago to manage
pension assets on behalf of the pension
fund so there my focus was really the
private equity the venture capital and
the energy head sperm markets mostly
manager due diligence and other buyout
opportunities where I was essentially
trying to manage a portfolio to
capitalize from the opportunity to close
those different marketplaces
so my crypto story really began in late
2016 early 2017 I had two college
roommates that were computer science
majors but back in college I totally
ignored what they were focused on as I
imagine most people did and then in 2016
2017 I started to take another look at
this asset class because I just saw so
much buzz around it and I didn't know
what words like Bitcoin and thulium
meant and I just started to do deep dive
because I was started to realize that
technology was the future and I don't
have a time it didn't have that
technology background so I really wanted
to collab attaint my career to learning
and getting more involved with
technology so that's really how my
crypto journey began that's awesome and
so you're at Citi you're doing a ton of
diligence on managers right and so it's
kind of a natural extension to what you
do with vision Hill as a fund of funds
but maybe talk a little bit about just
describing what a fund the fund is how
they normally work in international
markets and why you chose to go do
the fines outside of city where you live
absolutely so fun phones is exactly what
it sounds like it is a hedge fund that
is comprised of individual investments
in other hedge funds and the reason why
we do this we could talk about this
later is our no we want to capitalize on
many different strategies in this asset
class so in the traditional world know
what the equity markets are a lot of
long-only equity managers have
long/short equity managers and all sorts
of derivative strategy managers so in
this crypto asset class where you know
you're starting to see developments
every single day in maturation in many
cycles you know burner phones meet sense
to capitalize on all the different
strategies offered so bisman Hill
essentially was founded by my partner
Scott Army who comes form a high-yield
credit rating back my own to JP Morgan
and he was in conversations with a lot
of his peers to open up a direct fund
strategy and I met Scott through a
mutual friend of mine who essentially
introduced us because he thought assets
would buy a complimentary and the idea
before phones were started because both
of us realized that the opportunity in
front of us is absolutely massive and we
wanted to capitalize on all those
different strategies so vision hell is
very much a multi-strategy asset
investment firm that invest in other
hedge funds to capitalize on different
time horizons and the risk profiles
associated with those time horizons and
also different strategies got it and so
as you start building vision Hill you to
come together and was there a thought
process of there's three or four
strategies that we're really excited
about to begin with or was it we want to
look at the entire landscape what does
every single fund manager doing and then
we're gonna go pick the strategies that
we think are interesting great question
so it was more the louder no we we did a
bait deep dive fund landscape review and
we do this about two times a year so a
semi-annual overview so in the summer of
2018 right after a second quarter ended
we basically did a deep screening across
the entire landscape trying to figure
out who theme vegetable bones were and
what strategies that were executing so
at the time we had screened a little
over 300 bones and we identified five
main strategies that we curated into our
benchmarking work that we published it's
brilliant up publicly available for all
and those five strategies are
fundamental opportunistic quantitative
venture and smart bader and we can get
into more detail there if you wish but
more or less starting in the summer of
2010 we realized that these are sort of
like the five core strategies associated
with this asset class and each of those
strategies can break down into different
sub strategies that we can get into but
that's really how this aggregation of
our data came to be inhabitant hell was
starting to be built so just to give you
some context in a research and when we
did our second deep dive on landscape
the view as at the end of both quarter
we found we were tracking over I owned
four hundred and twenty five phones
well almost at the end of the first
quarter twenty nineteen that number is
now exceeding five hundred but back to
fourth quarter the phoned the crypto
native fund landscape aggregate assets
under management we estimated to be
about four point five billion and the
top twenty phones was comprised
approximately a little over fifty
percent of that landscape assets under
management so I'm just a recap there in
the end of q4 2018 there's about four
hundred twenty four twenty five funds
that it were existence but out of the
four point eight billion or so that is
in those funds the top twenty managed
over fifty percent of it correct our
four point five billion is what we asked
my comm and to put that in context as at
the end of the second quarter we
estimated the fund and say the crypto
native hedge fund manager fund landscape
AUM to be about six billion so so
actually between q2 and 2018 in q4 there
was almost a 30 percent drawdown in
assets managed by these funds that's
what we estimate um no capitulation has
been tough for cluster board and how
much of that is because the asset value
drew down versus like redemptions do you
know so we we don't have that data it is
something that we very much hope to
include in our future analyses but as of
the S at the end of the second quarter
the top 20 funds comprised about 40
percent Lance
and as a and the fourth quarter that was
just about 50% so we're starting to see
what concentration shift upward towards
top quality pumps it yeah it's the
concentration in quality right where
basically you see this in the liquid
assets themselves right so when there's
a bull market kind of the amount of
Bitcoin dominance goes down because
everyone kind of goes in all these
altcoins
and then when the bear market hits that
dominance goes back up because there's
that flight to quality and what you're
saying is basically in the fun landscape
you're seeing the same thing or if
there's top 20 funds are really
dominating in terms of AUM especially
during a bear market that's correct
and going back to a question about
Pharma damsons on the the average lockup
period for most headphones that we have
seen has buried between one-year Lea's 3
years on the longer end so any any
redemptions that happened you know you
still locked up for a prolonged period
of time so for the temp seems to have to
happen in fourth quarter of 2018 you
would have had to be in this asset class
in 2017 and then even still a lot of
phones structure their Redemption cycles
so that's staggered so you can only
withdraw up to a certain amount and then
you can go in to know whether it's
quarterly semi-annually and it can be
deferred to withdrawn and told that
staggered make certain schedule hits got
it and so let's talk a little bit about
the the manager specialization right so
you kind of named those five core
strategies that you guys identified but
maybe talk a little bit about you know
or make lets news first why don't you
describe those five and give a little
bit of more detail on what do you mean
by each of the five categories sure so
we also describe those five and now our
quarterly benchmarking pieces so for
anyone listening if we want to be more
comprehensively it is publicly available
fundamental I think is a pretty
straightforward no you have on one side
long only managers that really do a deep
value research and these guys go
granular to the protocol level to study
the engineering trade-offs in the
consensus algorithms so are certain
examples of that would be you know how
do you how do you reach distributed
consensus and what is the most secure or
optimized way to do that without
jeopardizing other factors such as
performance or
decentralization so whether it's loudly
nurses safety managers and loveliness
refers to our finality so finality is in
the sense of like how two nodes
communicate with each other to ensure
that a state is reached so that
consensus can be achieved and then move
on to the next transaction which would
be a new stage so it's essentially a
state transition function so unsafety
you propose to protect and against
double spans so when you think about
those trade offs and no Byzantine for
tolerance which is essentially
protecting against bad actors these
managers really studying at the lay one
level or the trade offs that the
engineers have made and then trying to
figure out which one is poised for the
largest upside potential and by capture
they're in on the other side you have
long short managers and tactical
training managers these guys are
centrally trading around the bid-ask
spread that's awkward by exchanges and
other over-the-counter market
participants so that's obviously a
traditional market strategy that is
carried over into asset class and then
you have hybrid managers that are really
doing a combination of those two and
also long tail venture illiquid risk and
those happen inside pockets where which
are simply just carved out allocations
for illiquid investments that are
separated from the main fund but I've
funded none the last by the existent
limited partners so that's sort of like
how fundamental breaks down if we turn
to quantitative you know this is also
continuing to be an interesting
developing sub as a strategy but you
have your mock and neutral managers so
these guys could essentially be doing
bases trading look at be doing exchange
arbitrage arbitrage you also have your
directional managers that could either
know be running some kind of bomb risk
model and a very
priority of factors there and so it
could be you know factors like momentum
like you know sentiment and
they trade based on those factors to
determine the direction that an asset
might be training on to capitalize on
any upside opportunities there and then
you're developing strategy that we refer
to as long vowel Tillery
and these guys are simply just trading
the Greeks so these are no you're not
just your your delta and the gamma but
also your theater you baker and other
poems' of our options web strategies so
that continues to develop but I think
this asset class is still a bit young
because there's not that much data to
work with no the fund landscape didn't
really take off until 2017 when we saw
no significant significant volume coming
to this asset class
the other strategy smart beta is more or
less our active and passive index in
venture is akin to traditional equity
yeah bomb no you see buy owns and have
your early stages and the late stages
and then the last strategy is
opportunistic opportunistic we separate
into two underlying substrata G's one of
them is credit the credit also carries
over from the traditional asset class
it's just taken the existing legacy
business model of lending and you just
have a new poem a crypto collateral and
then the last one is what we refer to as
generalized mining and generalized
mining is really just active network
participation so if you think about you
know blockchain is really just our ways
of coordinating human behavior so that
you are either contributing a
decentralized digital chorus to a
network and then either being
remunerated for that contribution or
paying for that specific contribution on
a given network so by essentially
providing some kind of supply-side
service tree being awarded coins by a
native network as are some good faith of
being a good actor so a really
interesting way to look at this is sort
of like the taxi medallion model it's
the right to work in a given system and
the taxi medallion could go up in value
if there's demand for it but it could
also stay flat it doesn't necessarily
mean they can't generate positive
returns because taxi drivers collect
their no compensation in u.s. dollars
for sure how do you think about
public and private investing right kind
of in the traditional markets it's very
well articulated very well understood in
this market it's a little bit different
in that you've got public and market
investing which is what most people
think of crypto right and then the
private market is really these credit or
venture opportunities how do you think
about that from a fund of one
perspective that's a great question so
exactly like I said public crypto is
really the crypto that most of the world
sees so these are your liquid listed
crypto assets like Bitcoin like either
like like coin and so on and so forth
and then on the private side you have a
lot of BC and hedge fund backed startups
that have created special projects that
are not publicly traded and we've seen
that continuing to develop so I think in
the at the end of the second quarter we
estimated the private market valuation
to be anywhere between ten and fifteen
billion and as at the end of both
quarter when we did our second deep dive
landscape review we entered we estimated
that to be about fifteen to twenty
billion and a lot of that was really
because we look in 2017 you saw the
potential for illegal securities
offerings in the IC o---- boom so that
shifted a lot of capital formation back
to the private markets because a lot of
entrepreneurs said we want to build and
also be regulatory compliant so we want
to raise capital to fund our startups
but also we don't want very kind of loss
so the way we think about it is you know
it goes back to side pockets and getting
access to illiquid opportunities while
also appropriately managing the assets
and liabilities inherent with bunch
structures particularly as a bleach to
terms but the private market valuation
has an interview shifted upward because
of the demand because capital formation
is done and continue to flow back to
know those private opportunities but
that doesn't necessarily mean that the
private market is gonna trade for that
15 20 billion dollar estimate I just
gave because that is really based on
post-money valuation which is a paper
valuation and doesn't necessarily
represent fair value it's entirely
possible that the prior market could
still trade a significant discount to
those post-money evaluations because no
worldly store in the scene in secondary
No I think coinbase was trading about
$60,000 we saw a circle trade at one
point I'm for about $25,000 and you see
simplified agreements for future token
saps trade at discounts as well for
other projects so no there's a lot of
opportunity there and we're starting to
see also a lot of those private projects
come on to me nutso cosmos just launched
last night and tamina which was a
private project that's now live in
public so we're gonna see a lot more of
those launches the end of this year it's
so interesting to watch the the nuances
of crypto from a investor seat right
because there are some things that are
very different and the network launch is
kind of similar like an IPO right liked
it to some degree and you got the I SEOs
which is another form of an IPO right so
you kind of have various applications of
financing mechanisms or kind of you know
networks going live et cetera it's
pretty cool to watch definitely give us
some some insight into the institutional
interest right so you guys basically
your job is to go raise capital from
institutions family offices high
net-worth and then you go and you deploy
it into all of these different funds
what are you seeing on the institutional
front so I think sentiment is turning i
think the announcement of JPM coin and
what Cambridge Associates the least I
think are two positive catalysts to get
people that sort of um were not excited
about the asset class in 2018 given the
price drawdown because that's really how
they look at the entire asset class I
think those are announcements got them
back to the table to say no wait a
minute maybe maybe we should taking a
look at this and then I also know the
whole question about whether we have
actually bottomed is containers to float
but I think the fact that sentiment is
turning people interested in trying to
look beyond just the price to Bitcoin
look beyond no just a public market
valuation and look at the private side
as well I think is a tremendous positive
not to mention that February was the
first monthly positive return since July
2018 and before that is April 2018 so
fact that we have seen upset by operatic
enemy sees sentiment is sort of store
and pick out sentiments very hard to
control right so I think institutional
interest is growing again whether or not
we about him do not wish I had a crystal
ball I wish I could tell you arm I think
though that there are certain factors
that we can get into that speak to the
possibility that we about them that
weren't around a few months ago one of
those factors is if you look at the
futures markets the backwardation curve
has flattened so the fact that futures
prices are now more or less stable
relative to spot price I think is an
entirely bullish signal and that wasn't
the case just a few months back and then
also in the maked eye ecosystem this is
a more granule example but the fact that
dyes trading below $1 suggests that a
lot of users are leveraging long the
price of eat because they don't want to
sell it and we can get into mechanics of
that peg if you want but I think that's
also incredibly incredibly bullish
signal because people don't want to sell
because they believe that the drawdown
has essentially no it's over otherwise
there wouldn't be leveraging long so I
think no there's a variety of
quantitative and qualitative factors
that could speak to the possibility we
upon them account I don't know but that
narrative was not the same just a few
months back and I think institutions are
starting to consider that absolutely I
attend to agree that the sentiment is
definitely changing and institutions are
surprisingly very in line with retail
sentiment right yeah and what you've got
to remember is I don't give your CIO and
an endowment or your an analyst you know
at a public pension you're still human
and you're still you know feeding off of
the same information whether it's you
know reddit Facebook or I'm sorry a
Twitter telegram etc that that sentiment
change is kind of happening across the
landscape which is important definitely
in sentiment seems to be know if you
think about if you think about it like a
boulder
it's very hard to control it's very hard
to control the direction it's very hard
to move but when it is moving in the
right direction it can work like a
tailwind
and I think that's a positive catalyst
probably buddy yeah for sure you spend a
lot of your days doing due diligence
let's let's talk about that a little bit
so maybe first of all just explain how
you think about your role in the due
diligence process like why do you guys
spend so much time doing it and then we
can get into what you actually do during
the diligence process sure so we think
of our roles as two things one we want
to be educational translators for
institutions to come into this asset
class because this asset class is very
opaque it's very complex there's a lot
of foreign talent and back-end
complexities that may not necessarily be
picked up by someone that's looking at
this asset class for the first time so
from a strict risk management
perspective we want to be able to offer
sophistication of diligence both for
ourselves and our investors but also for
all phones that we are diligent in so
that they are employing what we believe
are best practices for their investors
so it's really an alignment of
incentives there to just be as
professional as we possibly can to help
this asset class mature so the way we
think about diligence is really akin to
those five strategies that I just worked
it through and we want to have exposure
to all five of those strategies whether
directly indirectly and diligence
happens when we will map a fund that
looks institutionally investable and you
know it's transparent with their data
know whether it's performance whether
it's how they think about the strategy
whether it's our no just market
sentiment and their own arm narratives
but we want to diligence them from a
framework that we have vision Hall that
basically starts off by going deep into
strategy in philosophy and then going
granular into how do they think so its
quantitative and qualitative
quantitative arm kind of like a side
note one of our biases likes to say it
takes three years to get it through year
track record so you know it takes time
to build those track records and
nonetheless while we do that
benchmarking work that's publicly
available at the quarter know the
snapshots of performance at a point in
time and they shouldn't be indicative of
long
compliments of mining cabin managers so
a substantial a quantitative analysis
for our due diligence is still
relatively limited and on the private
side know when your private network
stack on public you know do you don't
have that many case studies of the
valley creation and all if I entered
into a private deal within one times
multiple capital and I was able to
generate you know whatever on the exit
multiple is hopefully it's higher than
one times
what's that attribution what's up by the
equation attribution in between point A
and point B when point B is public so
given that there's not that much
quantitative data to work with yeah um a
lot of it is really qualitative and
qualitative refers to how do people
think and I usually refer to this as
kind of like the the talent sack and I
think there's three ways to really
analyze this asset class
there's no from a financial perspective
how do you analyze token economics which
is a lot of it carries over from
traditional finance 101 and that can
help you understand how a network can
behave economically but then there's
current of are two other layers I think
one is what what ever further was
technical from the outside and then the
second one I ever thought of as
technical from the inside technical from
the outside I think is looking at
certain metrics that are available on
things like github to try to understand
develop activity so for example electric
capital just posted this fantastic state
of developers report it was amazing yeah
it was so good yeah that was those
really impressive and that really just
painted a picture of the health of the
development of all these networks what
the developers are working on how many
what the trend of that developer growth
is and on github know some metrics like
no commits and stars and watches are
great but no you just do have to be
careful that a lot of those can be gamed
and manipulated so that is all important
from a technical analysis perspective of
it but fertile ladders technical from
the outside and then technical from the
inside is really like I was saying
before understanding granule the
engineering trade-offs and a made by the
builders of these
portables in these projects now from a
security perspective from a performance
perspective you know if there are a lot
of disparate applications that warrant
different
language languages that weren't
different trade-offs and distributing
consensus know all up caution we once
said I know if you have an air traffic
control system if I'm an accountant
legend we have a social media platform
all three of those use cases aren't
going to demand the same program
language and the same security and
performance trade-offs so I think that
is all what are the photos cutting up on
the inside because they have to really
understand the decisions engineers and
Megan and also the trade-offs that come
from those decisions what brno abilities
are opened up what potential attack
vectors are opened up because of you
know some hood up decision that you
elected to make not to mention
governance no coordinating human
behavior and the division of labor is
all extremely important because you need
to think about what is sustainable in
the long run and how humans are
incentivized so that is one of the
photos technical from the inside so to
wrap that up that's really how we go
deep with the manager on the qualitative
aspects and then last but not least into
diligence is operational due diligence
so this is not just your custody and
your security and your asset
verification this is also what's
evaluation policy how do you mock you
know that what position some based on
what you determine so I want to get into
a couple of things so basically users
describe this there's a qualitative and
quantitative analysis of you know what's
your philosophy what's your strategy how
do you actually what are you gonna do
with the money they're right if we give
it to you and how will you think about
deploying it and what type of return can
we expect right or would we anticipate
current then and I think a lot of
managers focus on that right that that
is what their business is is I'm gonna
take money from my investors I'm gonna
go and invest it and that's the fun part
of the job the second part is this
operational due diligence usually most
managers actually don't like the
operational side of it because it's not
investing right it's the necessary evil
to the business and in this there's all
kinds of nuances right and in my
experience and the larger the asset
manager and the longer they've been
around they just have muscle memory
right they're able to say this is how
we've done this we've gone through a lot
of due diligence processes we've learned
we've kind of you know we're a
well-oiled machine in crypto most of
these funds are very young right year or
less old and so they don't have that
muscle memory they don't have you know
the 50 person staff they're trying to
build up for that but it's gonna take a
couple of years and it's gonna take
thereafter some profits to invest to
build that type of infrastructure let's
go through a couple of the operational
due diligence things right and so one
thing that you mentioned that I don't
think a lot of people understand the
nuances of is like valuation methodology
right so in the public markets pretty
simple we're gonna pick a date and time
and this is how we're always going to
measure it and what is the you know what
are we own and what's the price on the
exchange simple private mark is very
different so maybe talk about you know
what the challenges are on the private
market and how you guys think about and
talk with managers about that valuation
methodology of the private markets so
that's a great question agree with
everything you were just saying so on
the private side you know a lot of
managers choose to hold their positions
at cost which could very well be the
right way to go about it what we
advocate for is being market value and
it's very possible that cost and fair
mark fair market value could be the same
number but it's how you arrive there
that um can make auditors most
comfortable that you are employing best
practice so what we have seen some
managers do is create a framework you
know it's essentially a list of
parameters and no if you think about it
as less now
step one is going to be if this asset is
very thinly traded on a exchange whether
it's centralized decentralized you know
can we exit in a timely fashion how
would that be defined if we can't
because there's not sufficient volume
then step one cannot be completed that's
move on step two step two it could be
something else no can we drive a you
know internal fair market value estimate
based on some valuation methodology that
we could also get into well Sean there's
some challenges man that but if we can
then maybe that's fair market value if
we can then let's move on to your step
three and it's possible that if all the
above steps can't be met then step three
could be cost
based on that defined methodology you're
vibing at cost but quartz could be equal
to fair value so that is something that
we have seen some managers start to
adapt and as well as well as well
looking the command managers work with
the auditors
yeah and I've even seen managers who say
I'm going to mark it at the last
valuation that was validated by a
third-party investment with a discount
so I'm gonna take 20% off whatever that
is right and just they're they're being
overly prudent in a way or conservative
which i think is a really interesting
way of approaching it as well what are
some of the other things that you see
are really big points for you in the
operational due diligence so what we see
as really big points are business risk
mitigation so that really means is has
your management company been separately
capitalized to have sufficient one way
to cover the cost of operations if you
didn't get another dollar in the door
for a profit or a management fees so in
other words arm are you separately and
properly funded on your balance sheet to
be able to cover the cost of operations
and then the second point of that is
what assets on the management you have
to have so that the management piece
generated from that assets under
management can cover the cost of lab
solutions alone that's basically you
break it in point so what really makes
us comfortable is trying to see what
managers have thought about this what
managers have checked those boxes no
because otherwise the business risk is
too high you only have three months to
run your operation and not another
dollar in the door yeah they're gonna
have to waste more capital for your
management company or you're gonna have
to shut down so that's one key thing
what percentage of funds do you think
are making money right now
like they actually are past breakeven in
profitable so wouldn't they make money
do you mean profit or do you mean that
our hiring and management fees cover the
cost of the operation let's go with
management fees cover the cost of
operations so I think there's a healthy
chunk
I think there's absolutely healthy chunk
now the top 20 funds that we just
mentioned more or less I think all of
those are sufficiently covering the cost
of operation and now managers that are
no let's call it five million in assets
under management alas or still running
incredibly lean operations so the
overhead costs not the high even though
the 81 was very small so uh I I don't
see that as a viable concern for the
majority of funds in the SAS class got
it ready spend the last very important
back to about due diligence yep okay
what else so we talked about valuation
policy I think keep pressing risk is
also incredibly important because
investment teams given it's still
extremely early days investment teams
are very small and if you move one
person for whatever reason from the
equation no what does that do to the
investment strategy and the ability of
the fund to execute that investment
strategy so how key pressing risk is
handled you know is this succession plan
know who is the most valuable team
member and what happens if they are
essentially no longer part of the team I
think it's really important to think
through and I would say that's another
example got it and how do you see the
best teams handle in the key way in risk
so I see a lot of succession plans and
also it really depends on the the
chemistry between the investment team
you know how do you guys come to a
consensus an investment committee know
does everyone have an equal boat
no is it defined based on some
parameters and if for whatever reason
somebody were changed apart from the
investment team you know we see enough
talent in the other investment team
members to continue to carry the front
forward we don't really see any one
investment team member being so
important to the operation of the
business that if they had gone then it's
very unlikely that the investment
operation was shut down we don't see
that often but we we have seen it in
certain cases and that is nonetheless of
risk to be very cognizant of got it
let's switch gears and talk about
crypto and like kind of 2019 into 2020
what's your outlook in terms of sitting
in that fund of fund seat both from
inflows so institutional investors
coming in and then also from a strategy
standpoint which strategies are you kind
of most excite
about over the next year or so sure so I
think from a infos
standpoint the institutional interest
that we just spoke about a few minutes
ago I think is unchanging no I think
it's skeptical but from a healthy
perspective and that is my top two
control no it's not like it's like a
like a light switch so I think that is a
very positive catalyst between nineteen
twenty twenty of course the global macro
feels um based on the state of the
global economy but nonetheless if you
look at crypto in isolation of that
know the fact that they come back to a
table and may consider in Papua
construction in deploying phones into
this asset class I think is um extremely
positive and I I don't think many of us
saw that in 2018 so that's from an
influencer perspective from an outlaws
perspective right now were excited about
a lot of things um no we're trying to
gain exposure to those five strategies I
mentioned before um and there and
personally I'm very very interested in
deep I will open finance or some people
call it because I see that as you know a
very interesting news case um to enable
permissionless value transfer and all
kinds of financial tools for anyone
anywhere in the world at any point in
time so I want to go deep with you on
this because one framework that I've
been using is institutional investors
are still trying to underwrite fund
managers they're trying to meet due
diligence and underwrite humans defy a
lot of it is actually the humans are
taken out of the equation right there's
kind of algorithms and more automated
processes right you look at like a CDP
or anything like that
yep with maker how do you think that
well first of all how do you guys think
about the d5 versus like let's call
human driven fund managers and then how
do you think that the institutional
investors is that are a world where they
eventually just start actually getting
direct exposure to defy tight
instruments or do you think they'll
still go through managers who then get
the exposure for them
so I think on the stoical manages to get
that exposure on at least in short term
because the the can pony risk and Nikas
how do you actually custody these assets
and how do you trust in technology as
opposed to human I think is thought to
gray by now so I think a lot of
institutions would still go through
managers before they start to do it
directly um that very well could change
in a few years but by now I think the
best gets to a high um I actually
respectfully disagree with the point
about dpi being mostly machines way but
okay algorithms
I don't do it respectfully you could
disagree via really appreciate that but
reason why is because of this hypothesis
that the idea of programmable value
networks generating monetary premiums
it's very much a function of social
capital and social capital is really
just human connection you know you could
have small contracts execute all sorts
of code to create financial means
intuitive instruments and so on support
but how do you trust that way you're
actually executing a small contract on
is secure and that I think is indirectly
a function of the people that are
working on maintaining the technology
and also building the technology so when
I was going back to the idea of a
monetary premium know a lot of people
that look at the athenian blockchain and
think that it is accruing the monetary
premium because the sea it be used as -
as a value in certain things like know
and dharma or know collateralized debt
possessions maker but you know if we
take a step back and you think about the
human aspect here there are some
programmable public chains out there
that can compete with it as i doing
Azzam you know the if you want to call
it the winning public blockchain um I
don't want to say that really because I
think there's gonna be many different
block chains in the future but look at
you look at chaos if you look at Zelig
well no there's a lot of similarities in
the small contract computing aspect but
eat as electric capitalist state of
developers report has aam published III
Amharic Roode the largest number of core
developers and total developers and that
trend has been glowing and a very steady
pace throughout the last 12 months so
the fact that those people want to build
on etherium and the fact that they don't
really have many choices that because a
lot of the private
programmable networks no I'm talking
again near your depended your oasis and
so on a lot of those teams are still
very much operating in closed
environments so that talent is pretty
much not necessarily able to go anywhere
because the very confined to are there
funding that is backed by venture funds
or headphones and the etherium community
is building on a protocol that they have
a community around know and just to give
you some know flavor the strength of
that community DEFCON which was armed
no late last year I think three thousand
tickets were sold out in just mere
seconds so it's a very strong community
and the developers that are building on
that Network know when I referred to
social capital earlier if we move that
social capital that if those developers
were to go to a different project that
was private the one public or us or as
eloquent as ours would people still have
faith in the fact that each is a crude
monetary premium cuts being used nor
these different defy applications my
argument would be no because unless the
town can be replenished and the suit can
actually match that town with equal or
higher caliber no it's hard to justify a
sound in the same value to that same
digital asset so that's kind of a long
answer to a question why just great and
I think human connectivity is still a
huge part of all these deep I functions
it's just um not the same as having a
trusted counterparty and so wrapping a
lot of institutions would still rather
go the arm phone manager of app to have
a trust account a party but then the
defy applications could be very much
automated but it's still a function that
the valley ascribe to that is still a
function of the humans that are working
on it
for sure how does crypto do during an
economic turndown on the public side
yeah like some Bitcoin etherium kind of
all the public crypto because I think
that's probably the most volatile and
most likely to be affected all of a
sudden there's some sort of global you
know economic crisis or even just a
drawback in US economy cetera how do you
think crypto does or what's the
framework you use to think about it
sure that's a great question I think
on a public side at least uh these are
still less con assets so I think it's
very possible that they would have high
beta and similar to public technology
stocks no when when there's a drawdown
were concerns around the global macro
environment a lot of technology
investors think that the ability to
collect a claim on cash flow is distance
no because of our operational challenges
because revenue is slowing down
whatever the reason for the drawdown is
and as a result they lose confidence and
the ability to collect cash flow from a
particular stock and you know in a short
period of time and I think that very
much carries over into public traded
publicly traded digital assets because
it's that same sentiment if I'm losing
confidence because of public market or
Dione's even though there's no revenue
there's no no equity business model of
network networks and companies are very
different nonetheless I think that same
investor profile is in the equation and
if I'm losing confidence then I'm
probably gonna sell so I think no I
would expect digital assets and public
side to trade down just like public tech
stocks on the private side no I think
there's a lag I think there's a
three-year six months and possibly more
lag on private market valuations - or
the public market and the reason why I
say that is because public market
valuations in theory should serve as
reference points for what private
markets should be able to achieve in the
future and public markets or drawn down
them it's only it's only you know
presumed that private markets should be
able to power suit it just might take
some time to get there and how private
markets fail no I think the scarcity of
funds in the private market could bring
down those valuations and if
entrepreneurs are going to have to raise
capital on less favorable terms the cost
of capital is gonna increase and as a
result that could put stress on the
ability to grow their projects and the
companies so I think you're gonna see
stress in both the public and the
private area but the private side would
probably lag the public got it
do you think that these institutional
investors see Bitcoin as a non
correlated asset or do you think that
there were still so far in the early
stages of the education cycle they're
not even thinking about Bitcoin by
itself there's they get crypto as an
entire asset class like how far are we
on the separation of the different
assets and then also how did they look
at it in those kind of global macro
situations those are two great questions
I think I'm gonna answer the second one
first um I don't think that they
separate the assets in this crypto ROM
industry because they very much look at
the price of Bitcoin and think that's
representative of the entire asset class
so unfortunately I think it's early from
an educational perspective I think we're
gonna all collectively have to
collaborate to get them to understand
there's so much more beyond just the
price of Bitcoin in this asset class and
there are not answering a second
question I think that I think the answer
is yes and now it's yes to this sense
that they do look at it from a
non-correlated assets history has
largely been on low correlated to no
traditional markets but I also think
that it's by early know even though
Bitcoin has been in my own for about 10
years now it's still very early to have
probable data because of the adoption
curve so 2017 I would say is when crypto
fell on to most people's radar and then
we had to burn up and then them on down
so very much could still continue to be
a very low call it an asset but I think
as we get more years under our belt
that's when you'll be able to trust that
it will remain a low quality asset
absolutely before I finished up I always
do rapid-fire questions what do you
think the most important company in
crypto is that's going question
I I think the most important company is
I would say a company focused on
education so that so I think I would say
the answer to that question is really to
companies that come to mind it's Masari
and I think it's the block and it is why
I mention those companies is because
content curation and endpoint ask so I'd
say those three companies it's really
because content curation is so
remarkably powerful for expanding this
asset class from an educational
perspective and all three of those
businesses focused on different kinds of
content so it's really just trying to
get people to lead and any podcast or
Plasma and when the loves podcasts such
as myself although reading but I think
if you can continue to get information
into the hands of non-corrupt and
natives and get that distribution out
there I think that is one of the most
important things that we can ask for in
this asset class because otherwise we're
not going to be able to support the
mission absolutely if you could change
any one regulation what would it be
change or improve I would say I would
this is my personal opinion of course I
would change the tax impact around
trading crypto assets as property
because I think you know even if I think
it's two layers of complexity here one I
don't want to spend a deflationary or a
disinflationary asset in any otherwise
inflationary environment I'm much more
incentivized to hold and collect the
future rewards over time by doing some
kind of active network participation but
even if I had a stable coin like we used
to make at our echo system even if I was
able to take that deflationary
disinflationary ass lock-in and
Trustmark contract extract stable coin
and go ahead and spend that stable coin
I'm still creating a taxable event and I
think that is a headache for many people
that is know in a way um doesn't make
sense yeah it's it's challenging
adoption I think so if you could change
that to enable people to be able to
spend those stable coins to facilitate
points of sale and know much and option
I think that
would be a positive catalyst for the
entire asset class but unfortunately I
don't control the time what is the most
important book you've ever read most
impeccable bud how do I'm friends and
influence people by Dale Carnegie really
yeah
what what was your takeaway from it I
don't win friends and influence people
yeah I think to take ways one is listen
more because when somebody speaking
you're getting information and you know
some parallels to that's families
television hell but getting information
is one of the most powerful tools out
there you know if you're collecting
information from someone else know that
no life shouldn't be looked at this way
but that can know open up a lot of
different ways conversations can go and
in certain circumstances it can also
help you create leverage for yourself
know so that could help with any kind of
business negotiation anything like that
so I think that was takeaway number one
takeaway number two is you know at the
end of the day it's funny because crypto
is looked at as financial incentives
first and foremost but I think a really
important second part is their day of
human connection no it sounds a little
cheesy but no the idea of looking for
love money can't buy love people want to
be connected to other people and have a
sense of belonging and have a sense of
purpose have a sense of you know duty
and mission and I think people always
looking for that so that book really
helps you figure out how to connect with
other humans that may come from
different backgrounds that may come from
different no geographies and teaches you
how to create a two-way street in
conversation that can make you a much
better person if you have information
that you can apply to your own life yeah
I love that answer I usually end with
you asking me one question but before we
do a lien is real or not yes yes
absolutely why I think that the
probability that we are the only species
in this entire universe is incredibly
low I wouldn't necessarily say it's
nonzero but I think it's incredibly low
and I think it's only
normal to be open-minded to the fact
that there are other forms of life out
there I don't necessarily envision
aliens as a cartoon character with no
big eyes and big hair and that are very
well could be possibility but I think
that there are other people out there
and it's very possible that they have
tried to communicate with us already and
we just not advanced enough in society
right but I very much do you think that
aliens would you rather go to space or
to the depths of the ocean depths of the
ocean really wait why I am terrified of
space
oh man I'm the opposite I'm terrified of
the depths of the ocean really yeah just
like I don't know what's down there well
the way I look I'm scuba diving down
there No if something goes wrong my
chances of getting to the shore are
higher than apartment space and
something goes wrong getting back to
earth okay that's fair that's how I look
at it the best management downside
protection exactly exactly
all right one question dear for me so
one question I have to you is really no
obviously built quite a brand for
yourself and a following and you know
all your podcasts out which I'm very
grateful to be here you know your
Twitter following your on your
newsletter how do you balance your
social life with what is a 24/7 asset
class and also trying to you know
maintain the status that you have
achieved
I guess one follow-up question is if you
could look back would you do anything
differently that's a good question I
think one definitely don't have any
status right I'm a big believer that I
look at it as I put my ideas out there
and I wish that other people actually
did that more often and I'm doing it
from a selfish perspective because when
I put those ideas out there I get lots
of feedback very quickly on whether okay
am I on track am I missing something -
did I actually take data that was
accurate and applicable but I applied it
in the wrong way right like you just get
feedback and so it it's really from a
learning perspective - is how do i
balance it all
one I have an incredible girlfriend who
is a super patient and she probably
wishes I was on my phone a little bit
less but but other than that I'm pretty
intentional so I wake up early I know
that I kind of I write the newsletter
every morning before pretty much anyone
else is awake I'm able to do a bunch of
calls and stuff you know with other time
zones and then I'm I scheduled my
calendar in a way where actually they
leave early right so I don't stay in the
office until seven eight o'clock at
night it's very important to me to kind
of get out of the office go spend time
with her really do things other than
work even if it's for just you know an
hour or two every day and then it's also
the ability for me to seem like I'm
always on I engage with a lot of people
and all the stuff but there's times in
the day where I'll go three four or five
hours and I won't be on Twitter right
but then when I come back on I will go
through and it'll take me 20-30 minutes
but I'll respond to everybody and so
yeah there was a three or four hour low
where I didn't respond to them but I
responded and so they feel like I'm oh
he's always there he's always responsive
and it's kind of the the perception is
the reality to some degree and then
would I do anything differently I'm a
big believer in doing what you want to
do like there's a sense of freedom to
that there's probably some things where
people have said something online and
I've just you know I did the example
today somebody like brought a little
like water gun and I came with like a
flamethrower the top right it was just
like that was just my reaction in the
moment and try some of that stuff where
you know when you look at it six months
later like that wasn't necessary or
wasn't helpful but then there's an
element of me that says that's how I
thought at the moment and I said what I
meant right and I don't apologize for it
so I think that there's a balance there
that sometimes it's probably I should
have said that but also at the same time
what I do things differently I think I
would probably I wish that earlier in my
life I would have learned the secret of
I don't care what people think
and I'm actually willing to lose
quote-unquote friends or acquaintances
who don't want to be in my life for the
right reasons
so that is a really unique way of
looking at the world where I think a lot
of people are like oh I don't want to
like you know lose that friend I don't
want to lose connection with that person
I'm much more of the mindset of like I'm
gonna do the things that I want to do
and the people who want to be in your
life will be there the friends that you
have are the friends who want to be
there right that you find yourself
talking to and so I'm less intentional
about like oh I haven't talked this
person in three months I should go talk
to them and more of like do I want to
talk to that person right and so that
learning all of that I still have it
pretty early in life but you know the
earlier I would have learned it I think
that the more would benefit from it
that's great I'm really glad that you
are finding ways to have fun I'm sad
about what he's incredibly busy
environment this is a I am super
transparent the day that none of this is
fun anymore I'm done like if I wake up
one morning and I'm like I don't want to
write this newsletter I promise I will
stop writing at that damn won't write it
again right if I walk in here to record
one of these and I'm dreading it I'll
steal it early won't record that one I
won't record another one and so there's
a lot of things in my life where I've
done it that way and it's just let's all
enjoy it why like why we can because I'm
enjoying it and then when I'm done I'm
done and they'll move on to something
else
great yeah thank you so much for coming
man thanks for having me have to do this
again definitely